what up reject nation we are a day late
to this apologize just put up a little
too much yesterday but we are going to
watch today the moon night episode five
easter eggs break down from new rock
stars per tradition if you can leave a
like and if you haven't subscribed to
new rockstars because they're awesome
anywho let's hop into this people
welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of moon
night episode 5 which confirmed my
underworld theory but damn you hate to
be right if it means death by sand let's
break down this heartbreaking and
mind-blowing episode shot by shot for
all the details that you might have
missed and you can support new rock
stars by checking out our tomb of the
moon god shirt we're almost run out of
these over at new rockstarsmerch.com
getting this shirt on i hate that shirt
it's the i think it looks terrible on
people
ever seen in the cave as we hear mark's
brother randall
shouting now randall is the name of
mark's brother in the comics goes on to
carry the monikers of hatchet man and
shadow knight but um not here then
mark's mother snaps at him
and don't forget uncle frank look what
you did you little jerk
multiple shots earlier this season
focused on close-ups of dry sand of
course foreshadowing the sands they
would return to this season but now in
this episode steven's corporeal fate and
since those sand dunes are depicted as
ocean waves that the boat passes through
the drowning of randall foreshadows the
drowning of mark's second brother that
he created to help cope with the trauma
of losing the burst wow then we cut to
this goddess of motherhood screaming
which was directly from mark's screaming
mother from the mother mark fear to a
physically fearsome mother that actually
ends up being the nurturing mother that
they really need then to harrow's office
where he has fresh wounds on his nose
that were not there at the end of
episode four now later harrow does deny
sedating him so there is definitely off
the books violence with the orderlies
here but notice that bandage now mark
does have one of these when he talks to
consciousness in the comics that this is
based on but this is also the kind of
bandage that you would see on a boxer's
broken nose and mark in the comics was
also a boxer and i bring all this up
because there is still the unseen jake
lockley alter the fiercest of the three
we think of the sarcophagus rattling
like a boxer itching to get into the
ring but is he unseen because this altar
in this scene seems way more tense and
way more confused whenever harrow calls
him mark and oscar isaac is definitely
making different vocal choices here
you're not a doctor i always
yeah you see uh i had the thought go off
in my brain i know it's a very common
theory perhaps it is correct that that
is jake lockley because the thought did
go off in my head when we were watching
that scene however my mind also started
going well maybe i'm just looking for it
because he does seem like he's waking up
from possibly being sedated yeah he
looks like he's still groggy and it is
an east coast accent and mark is from
chicago even though that sounds a little
bit more new yorker either way i do
wonder if they would even reveal jake
lockley specifically here as opposed to
like some type of end credits or
something towards the end because the
thing that was throwing me for a loop
they've made it very clear there's a
third personality here especially in the
third episode when that third
personality killed that henchman but
they also had that line from the cab
driver being like why are you talking in
like a foreign accent or something like
that which led me to believe that jake
lockley might actually be some type of
egyptian character instead of the
traditional new yorker but we'll see who
knows maybe you're all right look this
episode started from the low angle point
of view of that mom just before she was
going to hit him which might mean that
in addition to creating the altar of
steven grant on that day they also might
have created the altar of jake lockley
in that moment to actually take the
abuse which might have led to jake's
extreme violence so in total jake to
take the punches steven to think he had
a loving mom and mark to live with the
guilt of it all so within the subjective
afterlife
[ __ ] mark's organizing principal also
created this inner office to represent
his self-doubt so it may be jake in here
and either way jake is left in this
psych ward meaning he still has a chance
to reconnect with konshu to rescue the
others then again in the next scene
retains what heroes said about
organizing principles so it's not
totally clear see see that too hero says
your brain is a pendulum swinging
between a very difficult reality that
you are my patient here at putnam
medical facility in chicago illinois and
a reassuring fantasy that you've created
on your own yes again the image of the
brain swinging like a pendulum sense
nonsense parallels the scales of justice
and the way heroes staff and the
lanterns
back and forth also putnam psychiatric
hospital is a facility in the jeff
lemire comics where mark's father elias
interns him after mark witnessed a nazi
serial killer poisoned as a rabbi
witnessing this murder being the
traumatic event that causes the id so as
hard as it was to watch a child abuse in
this episode definitely not as dark as
that what about yeah we brought this up
in the review portion of our moon
reaction my theory is that arthur harrow
this version of him is actually a
projection of a subconscious from the
type of psychiatrist he actually had to
interact with his younger years because
i remember that in the comic his dad did
take him there when you have to go there
as a youth oftentimes there's a
regression and unable to accept the
treatment because the whole point of the
doctors make him try to help him deal
with reality and cope with this
condition and so i do think that just
lends even more weight too that's what's
going on of why he has the face of
arthur harrow a clock appears on the
back wall just like the one in the rec
room hands also made of conscious staff
shape with a crescent moon tip and like
that one this clock also does not
actually move but the ticking is still
going and it's now actually grown louder
so that each really edits the shot to a
new frame right you're doing everything
possible wild and again my favorite
thing the timing is all weird too this
set in the office is the same addict set
from harrow's compound in episode two
whoa
white and black
said the layla oh my
god i'm going to die on evil magicians
man cave ah yes
wow we use that set and that same fear
of death and the cave trigger to
decorate to this representation of the
altar sphere within the duos holy crap i
love that
her ears constantly wiggling especially
when she's a little nervous her blue
fingernail polish which is the same
color as the paint on her chest scarab
this is awesome in the corner mirror
that is always behind her the vfx
artists always added her reflection even
showing her back when she turns such
great attention to detail here now she
says it's been a minute since we've had
a soul passing here which is a nod to
that rift between gods and man when
humans stop believing in the egyptian
gods and so naturally fewer people's
souls over the millennia would see their
afterlife as this egyptian duot in
addition to the fun animation i just
love the characterization of this
hippopotamus brought to life by antonia
selite
okay
here we go
welcome yeah her nervous apologies the
way she licks her lips and then when she
tries to clear her throat it comes out
like a hippopotamus belch look i'm
loving all these hippopotamus details
but i'm looking at do you see
mark in that mirror no
i wonder if there's some type of visual
clue here because in the mirror you see
steven yeah you see the dark shirted
figure in the corner far away but you
should be able to see mark i ca i think
maybe you i can't tell i can't tell if
it's the shadows it's wrapping around
her hand is up there and there's no body
of mark at all and he's right next to
stephen here the reason i'm breaking
this up because you know how they were
saying how mark was like the primary
personality i'm like maybe it was
actually stephen hey you never know they
could pull switcheroo on us like that
especially with what this episode does
uh try to convince us so heavily my
point being is if they're gonna make the
effort to animate the hippo in there
they would make the effort to put mark
in there yeah she declares
welcome
gentle travel
travelers
to the realm of the jewel
this is the afterlife the afterlife and
afterlife not the
afterlife
you'd be surprised how many
intersectional planes of untethered
consciousness exist yeah ah like the
ancestral plane oh just gorgeous yes as
i interpreted this hospital is the
subjective underworld of the mcu in this
case called the duat much like the way
t'challa and killmonger's perceptions of
the ancestral plane took the forms of an
african savannah or an oakland apartment
and this also suggests that there are
countless mcu afterlives that all take
various forms one of them was likely the
soul stone way station that thanos was
transported to i'm going to talk about
this a lot more in future videos because
despite claiming not to connect too much
to the mcu moon knight just contributed
more mc world building than anything we
saw in hawkeye or the falcon the winter
storm
team the hallway last episode to the
sounds of a creaky hole were indeed a
sign that this is all aboard a vessel
yeah by one thing
it's all that sunken boat and gus's fish
tank
i did not remember that
oh my god the sky of the sun world is
purple also reminiscent of the ancestral
plane when t'challa first enters it
frozen in the sand are past guilty souls
also kind of reminding us of the
scattered pruned figures of the void the
bow of this bone
[Music]
and a smaller one is aboard the rudder
torrent and stephen explained that they
are headed toward the aru the field of
reeds the heavenly paradise from
egyptian mythology only accessible if
their heart's weight balances with the
feather of truth to where it pulls their
hearts from their chests another indiana
jones reference by the way temple of
white stone maybe because disney plus
does not want a bloody pulsing organ but
also reflects how konshu is currently
encased in stone usha deform but these
scales are held by anubis who in
egyptian mythology is the true purveyor
of justice standing before ahmet unlike
harrow's scales tattoo which shows
ahmet's croc heads holding the scales
well speaking of which in the comics
anubis is the one who grants them
passage when they are in the void to be
able to get out of the other void and
back to normal world right yeah so i'm
wondering with the way how this episode
ends obviously mark has to fulfill the
mission he's not going to be just left
there in the field of reeds i'm
wondering in the final episode if you
will encounter anubis and will be
granted passageway
shows up like i got off break
i'm here to get you out of here kid yeah
mark suggest you kill the hippo steal
the boat but they head back inside to
try to balance their souls each room now
containing a dark memory from their past
kind of like the memory elevator of
inception but also a lot like in one
division another series that spends its
penultimate episode going down memory
lane we see the museum bathroom from
episode one and across the hall from
that steven's memory of rewinding the
stars in episode three with konchu that
room labeled treatment room this being
the traumatic moment they lost konchu
but the third room is actually labeled
with the qr code for the floor map and
when you scan this it actually takes you
to the comic issue of moon knight number
one of 1980 the first solo issue wow
character showing his origin story with
bushmen literally the floor map of this
hospital is mark's origin story
steven knows only their darkest most
unresolved moments are being kept here
and in the cafeteria remarks victims
from his time as conscious avatar all of
their canopic jars on the tables in
front of them they were criminals
murderers predators the worst of the
worst yeah thankfully the camera is not
on mark when he says predators because i
would not want to be the actor labeled
predator in this episode or ever but
also among these victims is randall whom
mark does still feel guilt for killing
it's interesting how randall is able to
move around meaning that all of these
other corpses are also mobile which is
creepy to think how they're all just
sitting here listening waiting to make
their move
or maybe it's a clue that the soul of
him is still alive and so you could
actually see him as shadow knight
eventually why is every other body
completely dead except for his huh well
what a horrific origin story that would
be and a great way to have some kind of
personal wedge between them you know
originally i don't get where you're
getting at with this well you know like
originated in in the afterlife and the
unfinished business of the trauma like i
don't know like because of the way he's
dealing with this
back to the video that's right i don't
understand steven follows row row to the
memory of the barbecue with their mother
wendy and their father elias come check
out my drawing he drew the fish with
only one fin mark be nice to your little
brother yeah i love the blocking with
oscar isaac and carlos sanchez who plays
young mark incredible performances from
both of them this episode as they both
turn to look back at the mom and then
back of their brother sinked randall's
drawing of the fish of course reflects
gus's nemo finn and the way poor randall
will end up unable to swim similar to
how gus perished outside of steven's
memory as steven woke up to him just
replaced young mark says maybe skating
a wild crocodile showing the origin of
steven's sign off with his mum he always
said that later gator's origins
and of course sets up mark's showdown
with the croc mouth of on it mark and
randall venture into a cave and steven
follows stepping on poncho looking bird
bones that could explain why konju takes
a skeletal form in mark's eyes when in
egyptology konchu has a living bird head
paul from heavy spoilers reminded me of
something which was that concho has kind
of always been with mark or watching him
right i really was in the main comment
that the lemares paul would run they
established that too that he's always
sort of been there with mark the entire
time perhaps that was a foreshadowing
clue to unveil that piece of information
as well
what
i'm sorry
the brothers say i'll be rusher though
can you hear that doctor ground i sure
do russell
sounds to me like danger yes rosser is
the name of dr grant's young sidekick
toonbuster being a movie that these
brothers must have watched together and
roro being his nickname probably came
from rosser and him doing the british
accent is likely what inspired mark to
start doing that voice to escape his mom
as steven pushes into the flooding cave
the sounds of water also play over the
shots of mark in the psych ward but we
never see the boys inside the cave and
we never see young mark escaping it yes
there are lots of rules about filming
child actors in water it's generally not
a safe thing to do but you can also
interpret this metaphorically mark
entered plato's allegory of the cave and
never came back out he never reached
your enlightenment you just remain
chained up in that cave only able to
perceive reality as deceptive shadows on
the wall but then mark enters the memory
of the ship there's just a child
yeah phil shout out to your service for
a close family member and i really love
that they include the detail of the
mirror being covered in this green
sheets
of household so that the mourners focus
less on themselves and solely on the
deceased that's a great call we should
apply that to all funerals i remember at
my dad's funeral all i did was look at
myself from the mirror stared is my hair
look at my own eyes as i'm grieving oh
hey all right
good give him a little blue steel
looks sad
oh yeah it's just really good people
sympathetic yeah i feel sorry for
raising my dad's funeral after all i
guess i'll carry on somehow
that was a good one if you think that
that joke is messed up you should hear
what the kind of joke my dad would have
made
this also reminds us of mark's partially
covered mirror in his hotel room at the
end of episode two a shot that also
prominently featured his star of david
necklace jewish confirmed the sheet slid
off throughout the series his mirror
reflection has been what's haunting him
everywhere now reflecting how he is
truly unable to mourn the staircase said
steven goes up has actually been seen in
the closing credits to every episode and
now we know why birthday
i love it i love getting that piece of
context
together but framed behind them in the
middle is that wet bar with the decanter
of boobs now steven goes up again but
just finds himself back on that same
floor impossible to escape the cycle of
abuse and now on this birthday the
decanter is in wendy's hand hey a pro
tip if someone is walking around with a
glass of booze in one hand and the full
bottle on the other just wait
there is a problem and poor teenage mark
finally just has to leave this house
actually behind mark in the scene is
this poster showing someone falling down
a hole as this whole episode which shows
mark and steven doing descending deeper
and deeper into memory mark and stephen
tumble along with the dig site incident
turns out going awol in a fugue state
gets you discharged from the military
didn't have a ton of options after that
so i went work for hire from my old ceo
of bushman yes referring to raul bushman
mark's mercenary partner in the comics
turned villain responsible for the death
of marlene's archaeologist's father or
in this case laylah's father mark
recounts how he tried to help this dig
team escape but ended up getting shot
himself and had to crawl into the tomb
of konchu now notice how the moon
overhead is now in its waning crescent
phase the crescent shape meaning consu's
power is rising we can also see the same
phase of the lunar cycle in the episode
5 credits which have been changing
episode episode so mark nearly caused
himself here as we saw jake tried to do
earlier with that paperweight but
conscious stops him
huh now it's interesting you could
actually interpret everything that
happened to mark's life after this point
as the judgment journey of a man within
the moment of his suicide which uh by
the way
for liam neeson and the great think
about it
i feel it fractured
broken
most fascinating
you
are a worthy candidate to serve me
during this time yes so konchu didn't
possess mark in spite of his d.i.d but
actually preys on him because of it and
there's a really quick subtle shot here
as mark first drifts closer to death he
looks up at the statue and briefly we
see konju's actual hand and staff before
that statue just a way of showing how
mark is already beginning to allow that
deity into his heart and mark consents
then rise
rise and live again
as my fist of vengeance
as
my moon night
yes the first and so far only time moon
knight has been spoken on this show
another parallel to juan division
episode 8 which ended with agatha saying
wanda's superhero moniker for the first
time in the mcu but that makes you
the scarlet [ __ ]
this is a fascinating prospect for what
they're doing with uh a marvel character
normally with this whole thing with like
a superhero hey i just had the word
superhero and he's not portrayed like a
superhero whatsoever like this whole
thing with conscious especially captured
in this scene feels like he's being
taken advantage of being like you are
fractured and now i will make you feel
like purposeful and complete with who
you are by becoming the moon knight it
seems like you know malevolent what
konchu's doing so i'm wondering will it
end in a way where being moon knight is
a positive thing
versus it being solely a curse not to
fan the batman comparison flame but i
feel like that would make a lot of sense
especially because of how they've shot
all the action that's like really harsh
like it's not cool hero action so yeah i
can see that turn happening and then we
get some cooler more upbeat action from
it or
something what the
hell are you talking about i don't
what's this moon night again
let me go on wikipedia i like how
various colors flicker across mark's
face during this transformation showing
the supernatural power inhabiting his
flesh as well as giving him this cool
suit back on the deck baboon scatter now
bathrooms actually play an important
role during the duo process carrying out
top's duties as the god of measurement
as the duties
baboons also guard the gate of the
underworld toara says i could kick a
baboon's ass
unbalanced souls are being judged to
condemn to the sands before their time
oh this is bad this is evil yes souls
plummet into the sand at an alarming
rate meaning harrow must have freed onit
from her ushati and is now wreaking
havoc on the world i cannot wait to see
this judgment process upstairs because
ahmet is depicted as a ferocious
croc-headed beast with the front half of
a lion the back half of a hippo tawara
and konchu are about 10 feet tall but
could ahmet be like a freaking
bust-sized monster
or is ahmed's judgment a remote process
that opens up purple underworld portals
beneath the feet of rotten egg souls
like veruca salt is that that poster
behind teenage mark was referring to
whatever it is it's gonna be wild i'm
praying to god ahmed is not some
massive
creature they gotta like fight in the
city or some [ __ ] like that because one
thing that a lot of people i think
share this concern not everyone but a
lot of people and i'm there too the fear
that they might drop the ball on episode
six after being so strongly character
driven and thematically driven that they
just go like too big
and all plot and all fight and all
action yeah i think this show they
should just get a season two and i'm
really hoping that that season two was
greenlit beforehand so that way we don't
have to worry about whatever they shot
already for the finale and that they
just keep it thematically and character
focused while wrapping up some necessary
plot but leaving the door open for
another season i don't want it to go
that massive because it already does
feel like there's a lot to wrap up yeah
they're able to convince dwara to steer
them back toward osiris gate and steven
snaps at mark if layla dies
that's on your head
it'll be all your fault no no no no no
you can't i won't do it i won't do it
you can't fight yes stephen accidentally
speaks with these torment words and mark
finds himself back in harrow's office
his face no longer injured just even
more evidence that the altar in the
first scene of this episode was not mark
or steven here harrow asks the core
question of the series do you think you
created stephen to hide
from all the awful things you feel
you've done in your life or do you think
stephen created mark to punish the world
for what your mother did to you this
really is the chicken or the egg
argument of the series who created whom
how far back did this really go
ultimately i think we did start with
mark i just like how this show casts
just enough doubt on the reliability of
this perception and we return to the
awful day it begins with a close-up on
the table as mark swipes the action
figures of dr steven grant and rosser
but really would these like the
tombstone poster truly exist as merch in
the mcu for a little scene knock-off
direct-to-vhs movie also considering
this is the science i hope so the 80s ip
as midflanders and the simpsons finding
nemo in both avatars not to mention on
the other wall of this room oh they
thought about that
star wars also on mark's side table are
a pair of nunchucks and a wooden scale
showing how even in this memory mark and
steven's souls are still being judged
and behind mark on the other side of the
room is the chicago cubs banner it's the
cubs
drawing when we clearly saw randall
finishing coloring in the fin as orange
on the day of his death and we see the
moment that young mark first creates the
steven alter
bloody hell
look at the state of this place
better out before mum sees it and folks
according to clinical research this is
how did manifests in patients often a
traumatic childhood memory in this case
we learned that it was mark willing into
existence an altar who did not have to
have this abusive woman as his mother
and might instead have a mother that
actually loves him steven notices the
tomb buster poster tagline when danger
is near steven grant has no fear also in
that poster you can see the split bust
of the aztec moon deity koyashaki now
side eyeing them but the poster credits
are filled with easter eggs timely atlas
studios timely atlas being the original
name of marvel comics
version of the moon knight creators doug
munch and don perlin melissa russell is
the wife of writer jeremy slater dylan
beck is the assistant production
coordinator on the show wyatt and dylan
curtis probably related to the producer
grant curtis colleen strasellowitz is
the wife of nick pepin whose own name
cameoed back in episode two carmel
benson is probably related to director
justin benson amy stewart is a partner
to director aaron morehead nor iqbal
mulvey is married to the writer sabird
perzada and i assume the other names are
just loved ones for other staff and crew
that is the most common easter egg
format in like any
anything isn't it if there's a scene
that has credits
let's get all meta here
let's put in cheeky names yeah
i really do respect the fact that this
show has taken a more
sensitive and sincere approach to people
with did because there are qualities of
this that remind me of [ __ ] like fight
club or the movie identity actually
especially that film but the way they've
done it here has treated it like the
other personalities are like real the
real people you know that do manifest
from
uh traumatic incidents like i said
there's a sensitivity treatment towards
it a compassionate way
not a like
mystery horror way because sometimes i
do it like who the hell killed that guy
here oh no what did i do yeah yeah in
terms of covering this you know there's
a authenticity to it that i really do
appreciate wendy moves in to abuse her
son but again this must not have been
stephen at the moment of the abuse
otherwise he would have remembered it so
i truly do think that the alter present
for all those beatings really could have
been jake but it seems like mark
remembers it you know yeah absolutely
it's his memory he would have the most
sort of callous built up for it
emotionally to be able to cart stephen
out of there and mark doesn't seem to
have any idea who steve who jake lockley
is yes and try to open the sarcophagus
if that is jake lockley in there when
that guy is killed there doesn't seem to
be any hint that mark knows of this guy
yeah they're already giving mark the
treatment in here as the violent
mercenary haunted by
uh all the the pain and violence he's
inflicted i i know that like jake's
supposed to be the one who can handle it
whereas mark is way down by the guilt
not sure just some of the clues like i
don't know if that's an actual clue i
like that it's vague enough that i could
see how it could easily end up being
jake but i'm not 100 like oh that's what
they're building up to yeah and hey who
knows i mean maybe the the other
personality isn't jake at all maybe it's
the astronaut guy or something like that
you know no
no no no but that's right improvisation
no but no but
this is a holy con an improv
that's right let me peel this banana
right here
stephen returns to harrow's office
gracie's harrow's diploma this thing
just says graduate diploma in psychology
no university listed no signature only
that he graduated in december 13 2011.
yeah it's a fake stephen makes another
pop
little haircut
little silly tash there it's very
ned flanders yeah the visual totally
tracks but also ned flanders is known as
springfield's dogmatically faithful true
believer as hero is for amit
steven's mom
don't you call mrs grant yes dylan is
the name of steven's tour guide
now coming back here is a receptionist
to this facility but steven doesn't want
the call to go through because he knows
that there will be no one at the other
end of that call just as there wasn't
for any of his calls just the dial tone
now no call was actually made here of
course this is just steven finally
facing his own truth at wendy specter
shiva mark stands outside in front of
the watterson food and liquor and nodded
executive producer trevor waterson mark
walks off and collapses smacking his
yamaka but then cradles it
yes this violent act makes him see his
yamaka as his brother that he still
feels guilt for harming and for a second
it seems like he's looking directly into
steven's eyes but he's actually
reverting into a steven alter hey mom
hey you all right yeah um
oh would you believe it
i am totally lost again i don't know
where i am if you look closely his phone
screen shows that he is not actually on
a call mark confirms this happened two
months prior as mom's death and shiva
was that inside an incident behind his
recent struggle to keep stephen at bay
stephen helps mark start to forgive
himself it wasn't your fault
and upon this we return to another
upside down overhead shot matching
steven entering the museum in episode 2
as they joined tuarex back on the deck
as they approach the gates of osiris but
the scales still have not balanced so
mark's past victims crawl up from the
sand mark punches one of their faces off
but he's still pushing back even
faceless steven grabs the rudder to
knock them off their balance then hits
them with that bat
six i prefer cricket yeah six is what
you don't want that goes to the back but
really just as steven did as a kid with
those spilled pencils it's left to
steven to clean up mark's messes steven
makes the ultimate sacrifice tackling
the last one down into the sand
stranding him in the doorbox bing bong
style all for sure
and did it suck for you getting rejected
from the fields of reeds what if that
makes sense because i'm not dead
remember first i said foreign
reaching out in the same gesture imposed
that crawly freezes himself
or wow higher power rules that ahmed's
premature condemnation of all those
reigning souls was unjust it's totally
possible that stephen could be part of a
divine retraction and could definitely
rejoin his altars in the living world
but
it makes me wonder then if that was it
intentional foreshadowing from the first
episode not a foreshadowing but perhaps
uh telling of of what was going to
happen to stephen a premonition what if
this is all in his own mind
all of this because would the girl be
talking about the field of reads and
then encountering the living statue yeah
is that an intentional sign that this
was stephen's fate but this is the
afterlife do you kind of get where i'm
going with a second i think so because i
feel like does this eliminate the whole
thing of choice if he is just ending up
in the sand to turn to stone getting
rejected from the field of reeds i mean
yeah that makes it sort of concrete it's
not only a rejection from the field of
reeds like mark come back but yeah it's
it's it's steven has been literally sent
to the opposite place of that which is
painful unless there's some kind of
weird time loop happening or something
like that or some kind of extra
you know outside the plane of space and
time sort of way in which this would
feed back into that moment or something
or maybe the museum is also a sort of
grouping
mechanism or something i don't know i
mean is the whole thing about the girl
asking him about not getting to the
field of reads and then the living
statue was that a sign that he was
always going to be turned into stone
maybe it's it depends on if the mcu is a
fatalist world or not i guess huh where
yeah it's like there are these clues
that hint to
just where you'll end up along the way i
mean maybe it would have interesting
implications especially in a universe
that seems also to favor a subjective
you know metaphysical
realm i'm saying that all this on the
boat and stuff is all in his head yeah
it could be no absolutely absolutely
could be and again i believe that jake
lockley is still in that psych ward and
if tuaret can make her case to osiris
the best warrior of these three altars
can take hero and omit to the mat but
whether by tragic coincidence or because
mark no longer needs is steven alter to
escape his trauma those scales now
finally balance and mark has moved to
the aru it's an immediate and smooth
transition as if he was there the whole
time just waiting for that amber
sunlight to beam through those purple
clouds now earlier tawarit likened the
underworld to the ancestral plane and
this field of reeds definitely resembles
a paradise where t'challa's ancestors
beckon him to join them but with the
sunlight and the tall plants it also
evokes the garden thanos's pastoral
retirement but ultimately for mark this
is not a paradise it is hell because he
knows he does not belong here music we
hear is masaya del sol sung by manuel
bonilla and santiago stevenson a spanish
hymn sung at funerals in mexico and
throughout latin america maybe a nod to
oscar isaac's guatemalan and cuban
ancestry but the lyrics translate to
beyond the sun beyond the sun i have a
home home beautiful home meant to convey
how in your present life you might be
poor and lost but in heaven paradise
awaits unfortunately for mark it is not
the st it's all about earthly riches man
actually just as the opening shot of
this episode comes from something mark
feared to something he wanted an abusive
mother to an understanding mother the
closing shot now cuts the same way from
the sunny field of reeds something he
doesn't want to the closing title card
that same field of breeds but with the
correct crescent moon shape overseeing
it all you can follow me on instagram
and twitter at e3
rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye what a lovely
breakdown
i just feel like i'm having a hard time
i don't know they did kang really well
but
the show's done such a good job on not
feeling like you need to read the comics
or something to understand i feel like
it'd be exciting for people to have jake
come in and like oh this is the right
personality to take on harrow but to
just be introduced in the final episode
would make it feel like a deus ex
d.i.d
moon knight guy you know yeah or maybe
he will be jake lockley here yeah
i don't know
it just seems like there's no purpose
for him this season well yeah because it
wouldn't be the same thing as
introducing a kang figure because jake
isn't gonna be the guy pulling all the
strings and be the answer to any great
mystery other than certain esoteric
mysteries to do with just the character
study of mark and steven and blah blah
blah but as like a big last episode
surprise or something like that i feel
like it might be a bit bewildering
especially because we've done so much
development on stephen and mark and then
to have this guy who's like a great
fighter who can take the hits and we
know nothing about him
you know would be a little strange
although i mean you know they can do
some kind of saw thing where it's like
you know we go back and we see some of
those violent moments and we find out
that oh damn like jake is the one who's
been like dishing out the pain
you know in some of the harshest moments
or something but still it just feels
like it would be too much of a left turn
it's an interesting layer to add but
it's not like a finale revelation yeah
i'm saying that do something with jake
like definitely have some more eluding
or something happens with mark where he
goes into his accent or whatever but to
have like a full-on featured character
of jake that's the part where i'm like
nah just keep teasing just leave him for
season two
i don't know but i could be wrong i like
being wrong if being wrong means it's
done right yeah that's a good one
we'll see how it goes i just i just have
a hard time wrapping my head around over
especially because the the finales of
some of these marvel shows often feel
like too rushed
and that's my main concern right now we
don't want we already got a lot of other
things to do so we're not focusing on
this jake guy is the main prospect but
we'll definitely allude that there's
going to be another personality who's
going to be more prevalent in a
follow-up season
all right guys well thanks for being
here thanks new rockstars hey let's do a
page
brian
perry
you have such a wonderful name it's
silky and smooth much like the egyptian
gauze that wraps mark's body when he
becomes the moon knight happy to shout
him out in a british accent and brian i
wish we could meet and spend some time
together maybe go out for a steak or
something like that you know do a hard
to heart you know shoot the breeze and
really bond because you could be
a very important part of just the
reclamation of the good on this earth
shout them out in the new york jake
lockly accent and uh you know
i feel like you'd be a fun time you know
you wouldn't be too serious about stuff
you wouldn't be like bogging down with
too much moralizing or whatever it is
you know what i'm saying
back to normal and uh yeah we would we
would uh uh harmonize well just on a
friend level we don't have to go out and
get violent with any no nick offerman uh
i think that we could go into the woods
together like thanos and
pick some ripe garden berries and smear
them all over our faces to enrich our
beard hairs i want every single hair on
your face capable of cutting a man's
flesh
christopher walken hey brian
you
are the best
love
[Music]